le lieu est protégée est gardé secret
car à l'intérieur christophe tétard
ingénieurs à poligny travaille depuis
treize ans sur un bijou de technologie
ce chercheur est tout bonnement en passe
de révolutionner le monde du transport
électrique
ça c'est la route ça c'est le bas de
caisse sous la voiture entre les deux
dany transmission d'énergie son film sur
ces 20 cm théoriquement on est censé
avoir beaucoup de perte d'énergie avec
notre système on n'a pratiquement pas de
perte d'énergie un voire deux pour cent
de perte d'énergie qui se fait ressentir
sur la facture d'électricité
plus besoin de bornes pour recharger
votre véhicule voilà la promesse de cet
ingénieur à l'avenir il suffira donc de
stationner sur une sorte de plaque à
induction
le concept séduit déjà les industriels
puisque une société vient d'investir un
million d'euros cette levée de fond
c'est un gros industriel français qui
qui nous suit depuis quelques années on
lui a présenté qu'on associer le la
primeur bouche du prototype et du
concept qu'il a accroché ses france
c'est un truc de fou ce qui nous arrive
parce qu'on cherche pas des clients il
nous appelle on cherche pas à 10 heures
ils nous appellent
voilà une célèbre entreprise française
de transport est notamment en train de
discuter avec christophe sur une
possible exploitation
les brevets sont en train d'être déposés
le chercheur se donne lui deux ans pour
finaliser le prototype